Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus jetzt freue mich sehr Dich
zu hören ich freue mich vor allen Dingen
heute auf das Gespräch weil wir endlich
mal das Thema jetzt behandeln dass wir
ja schon so vorsichtig um kreist haben
einige Male nämlich das Thema genug du
hast irgendwann mal dieses wunderbare
Buch in die Runde geworfen von John Nash
ich habe das das steht glaube ich bei
dir auch in deiner legendären Bücherwand
und ich habe das dann mal mir zu Gemüte
geführt und ich hatte selten so viel
Spaß bei der Lektüre eines Buches wie in
dem Moment aber ich würde gerne
einsteigen damit wir sozusagen nicht
Gefahr laufen in so eine was in so eine
moralische
Erhöhung reinzukommen ja man man schiebt
sich ja bei dem Thema wann ist genug und
wer verzichtet mehr und wer sind die
bessere Menschen kommt man da schnell in
so einem moralisches Dilemma hinein und
fruktarier sind besser als Veganer und
so weiter und das wollen wir eigentlich
nicht sondern ich würde gerne mal mit
dir darüber reden warum wir eigentlich
sind wie wir sind ja und warum wir immer
wieder Opfer sozusagen unserer
Stammhirns werden und unser Gehirn dass
ich ja vor 130 oder 200.000 Jahren
entwickelt hat ist wie es ist aber die
Frage ist natürlich verdammt es uns dazu
immer noch wie Familie Feuerstein durchs
21 Jahrhundert zu toben ja das ist ja
die Frage um die es geht und ich habe am
Wochenende eine herrliche Geschichte von
Ferdinand von Schirach gelesen der
folgendes erzählte ein älteres Ehepaar
gewinnt im Lotto dann werden die von
einem Reporter besucht kleines Häuschen
am Stadtrand schöner Vorgarten bequeme
Möbel und werden gefragt was sie mit
diesem Geld jetzt machen Antwort
größerer Fernseher soll gekauft werden
und es soll auf eine Weltreise gehen
zehn Jahre später gewinnt derselbe
Ehepaar wieder beim Lotto dieser
Reporter besucht die beiden erneut Haus
Garten Wohnzimmer alles unverändert nur
der Fernseher ist größer und er fragt
wieder was die beiden jetzt mit ihm
Lottogewinn machen werden und sie sagen
wir gehen auf Weltreise und dann sagt
dieser Reporter aber das wollten sie
doch schon vor zehn Jahren machen
Antwort wir sind noch nicht dazu
gekommen
das ist eine schöne Geschichte finde ich
das für schöne herrliche Einleitung
genau zu dem Thema um das es geht denn
irgendwie wissen wir alle immer nur eins
dass uns irgendwie etwas zum großen
Glück fehlt und es ist ein bisschen wie
bei Imelda Markus das schönste Paar
Schuhe ist immer genau das was wir
gerade noch nicht haben und ich frage
mich muss das eigentlich immer so
weitergehen
[Musik]
also du hattest ja eingeleitet und was
über das Stammhirn und so weiter erzählt
also ich glaube die gute Nachricht
besteht darin dass wir jetzt nicht
seit den Zeiten afrikanischen Savanne
vor einigen hunderttausend Jahren darauf
konditioniert sind
dass wir materiell immer mehr haben
wollen dass die gute Nachricht also es
gibt weder ein solches gehen noch eine
solche gehirndisposition denn wenn das
tatsächlich so wäre dann hätten die
Menschen ja in den Zeit des Menschen
gibt in den letzten 100.000 Jahren immer
so gelebt
und tatsächlich sehen wir dass es
Kulturen gibt in denen diese
materielle Gier oder dieses materielle
mehr ganz stark ist und das ist ganz
ganz viele Kulturen auf diesem Planeten
gab und auch immer welche gibt wo das
schwach ist
und das ist die gute Nachricht also wir
sind hier nicht ans Kreuz unserer
Herkunft geschlagen das heißt du bist
Anhänger der These weil darum geht es
nämlich auch das ist ja die ganz große
Frage diese Gier dieses unersetzliche
dieses immer mehr wollen ja ist das
etwas das uns angeboren ist oder ist das
etwas das uns an erzogen ist das ja die
große Frage ja und wie so häufig bei
solchen Fragen es konnte uns ja nur
anerzogen werden weil wir eine
Disposition dafür haben dass uns das
gefällt weil wir empfänglich sind dafür
das bedeutet bei der empfänglich sind
aber Empfänglichkeit bedeutet ja nicht
Alternativlosigkeit wir sind ja auch für
andere Dinge empfänglich na wir sind ja
auch für Liebe und Anteilnahme und in
deinem Kreis von gleichen zum Beispiel
unter Freunden unterwegs zu sein
es gibt wir sind ja sogar zum Teil für
Genügsamkeit empfänglich Leute die
freiwillig ein halbes Jahr in
buddhistisches Kloster gehen und so also
empfänglich sind wir für vieles und wir
sind dafür empfänglich aber ob das jetzt
dominant wird ob das unsere Kultur
bestimmt oder nicht das hängt von ganz
vielen Faktoren ab das hängt nicht an
der menschlichen Natur sondern du
glaubst das ist etwas das ist uns
sozusagen nach einiger Zeit beigebracht
worden immer dazu wird uns eintrainiert
das würden uns ein trainiert und wie
gesagt Menschen sind empfänglich dafür
übrigens auch nicht alle genau gleich ne
also es gibt Menschen so unendlich
empfänglich dafür auch übrigens
interessant manche Leute sind
tatsächlich so wahnsinnig
begeisterungsfähig für materielle Güter
also ein Auto oder eine Uhr oder so was
auch immer es ist oder oder vielleicht
auch ein Kunstwerk
dann gibt es Menschen die sind dafür gar
nicht so empfänglich sondern die sind
empfänglich dafür Geld zu vermehren das
ist nicht das Gleiche also ich glaube
tatsächlich dass viele Milliardäre nur
eingeschränkt empfänglich für materielle
Güter sind wir Warren Buffett zum
Beispiel ja und ich glaube ihr Elon Musk
ist das glaube ich ähnlich oder so aber
das ist eine andere Motivation ne exakt
die Motivation ist eine andere die
Motivation ist nicht ich habe dann
dieses Schiff oder ich habe dann dieses
riesige Haus oder ich habe dann 12 Autos
oder 100 oder wie auch immer oder ein
Rolls Royce Sammlung sondern die
Motivation ist immer weiter und weiter
und weiter zu kommen als Selbstzweck ja
also quasi zu sagen es gibt keine Wand
die mich bremst das ist ja nicht das
gleiche wie ich möchte viel Geld haben
weil ich mir dann viele schöne Dinge
leisten kann sind zwei verschiedene
Dinge wer ist interessant dass du das
sagst ich habe neulich ein Interview mit
mit Elon Musk gehört der nach Warren
Buffett gefragt wurde ja diesem
legendären Investor der vor ein paar
Jahren noch mal passiven Apple
eingestiegen ist und ich glaube auch aus
12 Milliarden Dollar sowas wie 150
Milliarden Dollar gemacht hat in
kürzester Zeit das ist ihre allein dass
jemand in der Lage ist so mal eben zehn
zwölf Milliarden zu investieren ja
allein dass man sowas kann und er wurde
nach ihm gefragt und fragte und der
Interviewer wollte wissen ob er
ein Bewunderer von Warren Buffett sei
und irgendwas gesagt sagte nicht
wirklich um offen zu sein weil das Leben
dieses Typen stelle ich mir unfassbar
langweilig vor Warren Buffett sitzt
nämlich in Omaha da wohnt der ist jeden
Tag sein gleiches Zeug jeden Tag in
dieser amerikanische Kleinstadt irgendwo
in so einen Schnellimbiss um zu essen
und liest ansonsten Bilanzen von morgens
bis abends Bilanzen und sieht nur zu
sozusagen wo kann ich aus meinem Geld
möglichst schnell mehr machen okay es
ist kein erstrebenswertes Ziel
Milliardär zu werden wenn das Leben so
aussieht aber jetzt frage ich mich
wie sieht denn das Leben von Elon Musk
aus hast du eine Vorstellung wer das ist
schon anders pass auf Warren Buffett hat
mal gesagt bei mir ist es so meine
Anlagestrategie ist ich kaufe etwas was
mir wirklich gefällt zu einem Preis der
mir wirklich gefällt und dann mache ich
20 Jahre lang die Augen zu und
irgendwann mache ich sie wieder auf und
dann bin ich wahrscheinlich ein reicher
Mann Elon Musk dagegen geht Spaß machen
also er muss ja irgendein Ziel vor Augen
haben also wenn ihm sein tägliches Leben
ne wenn er da so jetzt relativ
bescheiden ist und keine großen
Ansprüche hat also das stinkt
langweiliges Leben führt wie Immanuel
Kant 1 geführt hat also eins wo man
sozusagen nach seinen Spaziergängen die
Uhr stellen konnte da muss es ja
irgendetwas geben was ihm Befriedigung
verschafft und was ist das die
Formierung von Zahlen ich glaube schon
ich glaube schon die Anzahl der Nullen
hinter der eins bisschen spooky oder ja
weil Elon Musk sagt zum Beispiel das ist
langweilig für mich ist interessant
etwas zu gestalten etwas aufzubauen und
dann beschreibt er wieder mehrfach als
als Tesla auch kurz vor der Pleite war
wirklich seine letzte Kohle die letzten
zehn zwölf Millionen Dollar genommen hat
und sie in dieses Unternehmen gesteckt
hat zu einer Zeit als eigentlich die
versammelte deutsche Autoindustrie über
den gelacht hat und gesagt hat das ist
ein Irrweg das wird niemals
funktionieren du weißt ja dass ich Elon
Musk im Hinblick auf Elektromobilität
nicht als ein Teil der Lösung sondern
als ein Teil des Problems sehr ja noch
und zwar aus dem einfachen Grund weil ja
das eigentliche große Versprechen da
kommen wir unserem Thema genug na
das eigentlich große Versprechen der
Elektromobilität als ich mich dafür
begeistert habe wir reden jetzt sofort
Mitte der 80er Jahre
bestand eigentlich immer darin dass man
diese
Status diversifizierte Produktpalette
des
fetischisierten
individualverkehrsüberwindet und das
Auto als nichts anderes sieht als als
kleines leichtes Transportmittel
um mit der Hoffnung dass es dann weniger
Autos gibt das ist dann weniger Verkehr
gibt und dass diese Autos dann
Elektromobil sind und für mich ist
natürlich Elon Musk der Inbegriff des
Verrates an dieser Idee bei der hat
jetzt Elektro mobile
Status diversifizierte Karossen gebaut
das heißt er hat sozusagen den gleichen
Anreiz ja der beim herkömmlichen
Automobil da ist ich will ganz tolles
besonderes Auto haben auf die
Elektromobilität transferiert und wenn
du in ein solches riesenauto was was
dann da fährt ja mit dem PS zahlen und
der Beschleunigung und so weiter
schon alles über SUVs und so das gibt's
ja alles Elektro und im Grunde genommen
wurde sozusagen in diesem Problem nichts
geändert was heißt wir haben sozusagen
aus dem einen Problem ein anderes
Problem gemacht und wie du weißt denke
ich immer wir gucken nie auf die
Gesamtbilanz dieser Umstellung
also wenn man in Südamerika ist und die
lithiumfelder sieht die da im Bolivien
sind und sich vorstellt jetzt wird der
weltweite Verkehr auf Elektromobilität
umgestellt was da künftig an Lithium
benötigt wird und wenn man sich die
Umweltsünden da jetzt schon anschaut und
dann überlegt die Nachfrage der Welt
wird sich vor 20 oder vor 50fachen dann
wird mir sowas von schlecht ja was auch
ich habe ich habe noch mal wir müssen
gar nicht auf Elon Musk zeigen wir
können einfach mal auf uns selbst zeigen
bzw uns mal ein paar Fakten anschauen
Richard also deswegen die Frage brauchen
wir eine Kultur des genug wann sind wir
sozusagen zufrieden und warum können wir
komischerweise nie genug kriegen neulich
eine Statistik gelesen über fünf
Milliarden Kleidungsstücke hängen in
Deutschlands Schränken
das macht pro Kopf 95 Kleidungsstücke
und nur jedes fünfte davon tragen wir ja
ja
Kleidung ist absolute mehr CO2 Ausstoß
als Flugverkehr und Kreuzfahrtschiffe
zusammen ja ja also ich das ist übrigens
der tritt sie jetzt bei mir eine offene
Tür an jeder ja es ist ja bei jedem was
anderes oder ja also der eine der eine
kann da besser Schwan der andere könnte
da besser sparen im einen macht das was
auseinander macht das was aus und man
kann ja nie sagen das was einem jetzt
selber nicht so besonders wichtig ist da
soll man jetzt mal alle mal anfangen zu
sparen na dann sind wir in der
moralischen Diskussion da kann ja nur
aus seiner eigenen persönlichen
Perspektive sagen und da ist es bei mir
also Klamotten wäre oder kann ich
wunderbar anspannen
bist du guter Mensch ja da bin ich ein
guter Mensch aber nicht aber nicht aber
nicht weil ich mir vornehme ein guter
Mensch zu sein weil es mir so leicht
fällt ein guter Mensch zu sein weil er
nicht der Hauptfokus meines Interesse
ist drauf liegt ja so rum ist es ja
genau aber du merkst es kommt sofort ein
guter Mensch zu sein weil ich kein Auto
besitze ja ich besitze aber nicht es ist
aber nicht so dass ich sage ich habe mir
mal nach einer langen moralischen
Reflexion überlegt ich will kein Auto
haben völliger Quatsch ja pass auf das
ist jetzt genau der Punkt ich fühle mich
jetzt schon wieder mies ne ich ich habe
finde ich gut ja
ich habe ein paar Klamotten im Schrank
tatsächlich stehe auch dazu ich ziehe
auch die meisten davon nie an das ist
alles gerümpelt dass ich im Laufe der
Zeit so gesammelt hat und ich denke
manchmal ja es stimmt wir alle wenn wir
mal ehrlich sind wir kaufen so viel Zeug
so viele Kumpels wir irgendwann von dem
ganzen Krempel einfach erschlagen werden
ja irgendwann wird irgendein Stapel
zusammenfallen und dann war es das und
es gibt irre Untersuchungen zu dem Thema
wusstest du zum Beispiel dass in England
aber auch in den USA und ich schätze mal
in Deutschland ist jetzt nicht viel
anders es gibt mittlerweile Leute die
ein wahnsinnsgeschäft machen mit dem
Vermieten von Lagerflächen für
Privathaushalte
du kannst dich von nicht aber alles das
was man auslagern kann das muss man doch
auch gar nicht mehr haben oder das ist
der Punkt aber sie machen es trotzdem
und es ist auch keine Frage sozusagen
von viel Geld oder wenig Geld in den USA
gibt es Untersuchungen Leute die zum
Teil 25.000 Dollar im Jahr verdienen das
ist wirklich nicht viel
auch die haben solche Lagerflächen die
Anbieter solcher Lagerflächen verdienen
sich domodus Licht und die die gut
verdienende obere Mittelschicht ja im
Bereich Friedrich Merz die haben diese
Lagerflächen weil sie ja den schönen
Dielenboden zu Hause irgendwann auch
noch mal sehen wollen das heißt du
willst nicht alles zustellen und dann
hast du hast du diese Lagerflächen aber
übrigens zum Thema an die eigene Nase
fassen ne also hier in der Kemenate sind
ja auch sehr sehr viele Bücher und ich
meine überleg mal wie viel Bäume das
sind
ach Gott sei Dank jetzt fühlt sich auch
endlich schlecht nein es ist ja Bücher
wird immer so positiv angesehen aber ich
sag jetzt mal den sicher die ich mir um
die Nase fliegenden Satz aber
unglaublich viel von dem was gedruckt
wird braucht die Welt nicht man gibt es
ja keinen Sensor der keinen Sensor der
darüber entscheidet ja aber
ja
wenn du dich in ein Gebiet einarbeiten
hast du geschrieben bis jetzt
19 okay und Gesamtauflage
doch das weiß ich ehrlich nicht aber
ganz ehrlich nicht Millionen ja weißt ja
wie viele Bäume das sind ja ich glaube
mich nur noch erschießen jetzt hast du
mich erwischt mit einem vollen Schrank
ja so einfach geht das
und auch wenn du noch überlegst was ich
alles gekauft habe und mehr oder weniger
gelesen oder angefasst oder
durchgeblättert und so weiter ne auch
diese ganzen Bäume müssen wir ja dazu ja
ich muss gar nicht auf dir rumhacken ich
kann auch mal auf der bösen Industrie
rumhacken ja in einem deiner Bücher
übrigens folgende Tage gefunden mehr als
10 Millionen Roboter gab es im Jahr 2020
auf der Erde 10 Millionen Roboter es
gibt aber nur noch 400.000 Elefanten
30.000 Nashörner und 20.000 Löwen
das heißt die von menschengemachte Welt
nimmt zu und die natürliche Welt nimmt
ab richtig das ist das was wir uns bauen
150.000 Tonnen Elektroschrott nur aus
Deutschland landet jedes Jahr in Ghana
es gibt Untersuchungen ja es gibt es
gibt eine Untersuchung von von Forschern
der der Technischen Universität in
Dresden die im ausgerechnet dass das Web
im Jahr 2030 ich meine das ist
übermorgen so viel Strom verbrauchen
wird wie die gesamte Weltbevölkerung im
Jahre 2011 lass dir das mal auf der
Zunge zergehen ja das ist also das ist
das große unterschätzte Problem der
Digitalisierung immer noch also es gibt
natürlich sehr viele kluge Leute die
daran arbeiten
Digitaltechnik weniger in
energieintensiv zu machen also weniger
Strom verbraucht und so aber insgesamt
weitet sich natürlich die
Digitalisierung immer stärker aus ja
also wenn jetzt ich jetzt schon an dem
Pranger stehe wegen meiner Bücher und du
wegen deines gigantischen Kleiderschrank
unfassbar groß vorstellen ja
wahrscheinlich auch noch angereichert
mit immer den gleichen Sachen weil die
in seiner Sendung ja fast das gleiche
trägst in tausend Varianten so aber die
1000 Varianten die etwas machen
aber etwas was ich in meinem Leben
niemals machen würde aus moralischen
Gründen Netflix Serien schauen was
meinst du was das ein Energieverbraucher
Streaming ja zum Beispiel Streaming
Streaming ist gigantisch also im
weltweiten Verbrauch und das wird immer
mehr und immer mehr und immer mehr ja
das war natürlich nicht ernst gemeint
dass ich das aus ökologischen Gründen
nicht machen würde ich will nur sagen ja
wie auch immer man das Pferd aufzäumt am
Ende ist ja klar also ich meine so eine
völlig enthaltsame Lebensweise ja wäre
dann das am besten verträglicher aber
wer stellt sich denn hin und würde ganz
ernsthaft sagen pass mal auf Leute jetzt
fangen wir alle an und leben wie Jesus
das nächste Problem wäre bei uns wird
die Krieg ausbrechen weil unsere ganze
Wirtschaft ist auf Konsum und Wachstum
ausgerichtet unsere sozialen
Sicherungssysteme hängen davon ab ja
also wir könnten keine Rente mehr
kriegen eine Krankenversicherung mehr
nicht mehr bezahlbar und so weiter wenn
wir kein Wachstum haben
und das ist natürlich das echte Problem
das echte Problem ist nicht ob Du oder
ich an der Stelle oder einer anderen
Stelle eher verzichten oder ihr gierig
sind sondern das Hauptproblem ist dass
wir in einem System leben in dem
Verzicht nicht vorgesehen ist und zwar
systematisch nicht vorgesehen 1957 wird
der der Begriff Society ja
Überflussgesellschaft das erste Mal
geprägt ja weil da irgendwie klar ist
jetzt ist im Grunde genommen genug da
und es war aber nicht so dass die
Menschen sagen weil des deutschen
Wirtschaftswunders 1957 gesagt hätten
wir auch jetzt haben wir eigentlich
genug ne jetzt könnte sich kann sich
jeder zehnte von uns ein VW Käfer
leisten ja und jeder 100 sagten
Fernseher und so das war ja so ungefähr
die Situation 1957 genau sondern das war
klar dass diese ganzen neu erfundenen
Produkte Fernseher haben zu wollen Auto
haben zu wollen Kühlschrank
kasselbad ja das war ja Traum der 50er
Jahre ja wir hatten und und Essen aus
Dosen Essen aus Dosen trumpfhaft
übrigens auch eine Atomkraft war eine
Versprechung damals ne das war das war
ganz teuer dann wurde richtig für
geworben es gab Comics in denen
Atomkraft irgendwie beschworen wurde und
den Leuten nahe gebracht und sowas mal
alles damit machen kann Fleisch jeden
Tag ja auch ein riesiges Versprechen
einer Generation ja die die die
nachkriegs- und Kriegswinter erlebt
hatte
ja so und diesen Menschen zu sagen jetzt
jetzt erstmal Schluss jetzt habt ihr
eigentlich genug weil wenn das noch mehr
ist dann gibt's irgendwie ökologische
Schäden und folgen und so weiter das man
könnte eine Serie machen mit dem
jetztigen Know-how ja über die Umwelt
den co2-ausschuss ist immer die Rede
davon in den letzten 50 Jahren wurde
mehr CO2 in die Luft geblasen ja als die
Menschheitsgeschichte vorher
zwei Milliarden Tonnen jedes Jahr nur
die Textilindustrie statt diesmal so
extrem weil die Uhr 50 Jahre zurück ja
jetzt sind wir im Jahr was ist das dann
1962 oder 50 Jahre 72 ja ja 72 und sagen
1972 so jetzt
wissen wir das alles
und jetzt machen wir alles anders
diesmal machen wir alles anders glaubst
du die würden das hinkriegen stell dir
jetzt vor Willy Brandt ja sagt genug ist
genug wird unsere Wirtschaft darf nicht
weiter wachsen
wir brauchen innerhalb von wenigen
Jahren den komplett Umstieg von der
Kohle das war ja gerade die Zeit als es
überhaupt in der Kernenergie losging ja
wir gehen nicht auf Kernenergie wir
machen wirklich erneuerbare Energien und
so stellen wir uns dann um und so weiter
es wäre alles nie nie passiert ich weiß
doch selber noch von Anti akw-demos wo
ich als Kind war Mitte der 70er Jahre ne
meine Eltern haben mich aber sowas
mitgenommen ich bin ja ideologisch
sozusagen frühzeitig konditioniert
worden ich ich nicht weil wir hatten
kann ich weiß ja ja vom Berg weißt du
das war das Ding ja der Unterschied
zwischen uns beiden auch dass du als
Kind nicht auf einer Demo war
1972 schon auf meiner ersten Demo
für kleine Klassen
ja gegen Nordrhein-Westfalen 40 Kinder
sind zu viel 25 unser Ziel haben wir
skandiert ja da war ich im zweiten
Schuljahr großartig ja und ich hatte
einen vorne stand das drauf und hinten
stand drauf ich will in eine kleine
Klasse süß ne ja schon ich glaube ja
wenn man diesen sozusagen dieser Gier
nach immer mehr auf die Spur kommen will
ne
ist es dann vielleicht schlau wenn man
sich sozusagen die Evolution mal anguckt
also man sich überlegt wir sind
eigentlich sind wir trocken Nasenaffen
und in unserer Sippe in unserer Sippe ja
auf dem auf dem affenhügel ist der der
Chef der sozusagen auf dem Felsen ganz
oben sitzt da mache ich nicht mit mit
dem Bild also so ist das bei Pavian ja
so ist das aber bei keinem einzigen
Menschenaffen unsere nächsten Verwandten
haben nicht oben auf dem Hügel gesessen
was ist es dann ist John Nash geht der
der These nach also er sagt wir sind
Meister des nachahmens ja also Tiere
Armen sich auch gegenseitig nach das hat
man ja in vielen Experimenten immer
wieder manche Tiere manche genau aber
nie übrigens nur am Rande ja
schimpansenarmen sich nach Gorillas
nicht
aber Schimpansen sind unsere näheren
vorhanden okay also wir kommen sozusagen
von den nachahmungsaffen ja wir sind
eigentlich im Bereich schimpanseehe zu
Hause total so und niemand ist aber so
perfekt wie wir in der Lage auch andere
Techniken zu kopieren also wir können
ganz clever uns beim anderen Schimpansen
abgucken was der jetzt gerade macht und
das machen wir dann auch und dann
funktioniert das also die Arme das
sozusagen perfekt nach so funktioniert
kultureller Evolution genau und dann
tatsächlich die Definition also die
Definition von von kultureller Evolution
hat ihren Ausgangspunkt in Affen die in
Japan rotgesichtsmakaken auf einer
einzigen Insel hat ein Affenweibchen
angefangen die Kartoffeln die Sie essen
vorher im Meer zu waschen und irgendwann
haben das alle gemacht großartig und das
ist der der sozusagen da sieht man in
der primatologie den Anfang Kultur
Revolution also Evolution durch
Nachahmen und lernen das meine ich doch
so aber worauf ich hinaus will es wenn
das so ist wenn wir sozusagen lernen
durch Nachahmen wenn wir uns
weiterentwickeln Evolution durch
Nachahmen könnte es sein dass wir
gelegentlich dann mal ein bisschen
genauer hingucken müssen wen wir
eigentlich nachahmen also finde ich gut
ja also erstmal auf das heute übertragen
ja also müssen wir da nicht drauf achten
dass wir die richtigen Leute nachahmen
und nicht jetzt vielleicht unbedingt
weil sie nicht Kim Kardashian
ist das denn die Frage ist das ist dir
sozusagen der die falsche Abzweigung die
wir nehmen ja also es ist tatsächlich so
dass alles was Glanz und Glamour
versprüht natürlich irgendwie uns
stärker ins Auge Haut als Tagesablauf
wie der von Warren Buffett das ist sowas
haben wir gar keine Lust dazu das
nachzuweisen also wenn wir etwas
nachahmen wollen muss es ja irgendwie
auch mit Freude oder mit Stolz oder mit
alten Begriff mit eher Gefühl oder mit
irgendwie sowas zu tun haben deswegen
machen wir das nach
und es gibt natürlich auch Menschen die
sich Vorbilder gesucht haben die
irgendwie bescheiden sind oder Verzicht
predigen oder so das gibt es ja alles in
der Gesellschaft ich meine in einem
freien Land darf sich ja jeder die
Vorbilder suchen der die er haben will
aber ich möchte mit dir Markus weil das
ist für dieses Thema so wichtig sagen es
stell dir mal vor wir hätten tatsächlich
diesen Bewusstseinswandel nicht nur in
der Theorie da haben wir ihn ja schon
sondern in der Praxis und die Leute
würden radikal nach dem Prinzip leben ja
genug ist relativ schnell erreicht
was würde dann stell dir das mal stell
dir das jetzt mal als Streaming Serie
vor
ein Land beschließt das von heute auf
morgen das Wetter wohl passieren
industriebericht zusammen ist richtig
die Leute würden sagen es reicht wenn
man alle 20 Jahre neues Auto kauft wenn
das andere kaputt ist definitiv kaputt
so das wäre wäre für die
Automobilindustrie nicht gut die
deutsche könnte damit leben weil sie
mehr Autos in China verkauft aber wir
gehen mal davon aus die Chinesen würden
das auch sein
wir hätten eine riesen Problem also
Verzicht ist der größte Angriff auf die
Stabilität unseres Wirtschafts- und
Gesellschaft genau und und da kommen
doch wieder an diesen spannenden Punkt
Richard das ist und das ist finde ich
die ganz große Frage ist das alles
sozusagen nur Marketing Gag auf dem wir
da reinfallen fallen wir sozusagen auf
diese ganzen auf die geheimen Verführer
ja du erinnerst dich dieses berühmte
Buch die Marketing und Werbung
Spezialisten auf die wir reinfallen
indem sie uns jeden Tag bombardieren mit
irgendwas und Bedürfnisse wecken wir
sagen was auf das ist das Produkt das
wir gerne hätten und die sagen guck mal
zufällig haben wir das gerade im Angebot
genau und so funktioniert das ganze Ding
aber aber es gibt etwas und unter
stolpert man immer wieder darüber wenn
sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt zum
Beispiel eine Studie von damals hießen
die noch Daimler Chrysler die haben mal
geguckt was passiert im Gehirn von
Männern wenn man ihnen Bilder von
Sportwagen zeigt und du ahnst es werden
die ähnlichen oder die gleichen hirnare
aktiviert wie bei der Einnahme von
Drogen oder Alkohol wobei man die Frage
stellen muss ob das nicht das gleich ist
ja oder auch bei Sex zum Beispiel
also das
belohnungssystemt Dopamin Endorphine
also ist diese worauf ich hinaus will
ist dieses dieser Wunsch nach mehr diese
Gier ist das nicht etwas was vielleicht
doch in uns drin ist und ja aber es
müsste ja nicht aber jetzt kommt der
entscheidende Punkt er müsste ja nicht
durch Sportwagen ausgelöst werden
verstehste das ist eine kulturelle
Konditionierung also ich meine solange
es keine Sportwagen gab hat keiner von
Sportwagen geträumt
sondern der dass der Sportwagen jetzt so
so eine hohe Bedeutung hat dass er
sozusagen erotisches Objekt geworden ist
begehrensobjekt geworden ist das ist
ganz ganz stark kulturbedingt
und wenn jetzt weil ich meine das
Belohnungszentrum kann ja durch vieles
aktiviert werden ja also durch
körperliche Freuden
oder ja Rauschmittel in begrenzt Maßen
genossen und so weiter also es muss sich
nicht auf diese Objekte konzentrieren
wir haben ja auch noch folgendes Problem
materielle Dinge das ist ja eine sehr
bekannte Weisheit aus der
Sozialpsychologie und auch aus der
Individualpsychologie materielle Dinge
machen ja nicht dauerhaft glücklich also
materielles macht nur dann dauerhaft
glücklich wenn es ständig ausgetauscht
wird aber neues Auto da geht man rein
und dann riecht man wahrscheinlich in
diesem neuen Auto und dann fährt man man
dann fährt man Strecken die man gar
nicht fahren muss weil es so wunderbar
ist in diesem Auto auf dem Felsen und
wie auch immer zu sitzen ja aber nach
fünf sechs Jahren ist von diesem Gefühl
noch zehn Prozent da
ja wahrscheinlich das wird ja immer
weniger und immer weniger muss ja immer
wieder nachgerüstet werden und dann
guckt man sich das Nachfolgemodell oder
nach Nachfolgemodell an findet das
plötzlich viel toller als das was man
hat
Jonas schreibt in seinem Buch übrigens
ein herrlichen Satz dazu dass wir so
gierig sind hat was mit unserem
Dopaminsystem im Kopf zu tun die Areale
also jetzt kommt die auch von Heroin und
Kokain angeregt werden treiben uns auf
die Suche nach allem nach Sex nach
Drogen und den Hungerzeiten auch nach
Würstchen
das wiederum ist richtig so so und jetzt
ist es natürlich interessant jetzt
könnte man sagen ja gut der Mensch ist
ja nicht frei ne der ist also sozusagen
dem Spielball seiner Neurotransmitter
genau ausgesetzt weil dopamin ist ja
nicht der einzige also wenn du dopamid
uns antreibt die anderen drei
Neurotransmitter die deine
Werkseinstellung bestimmen die haben ja
auch einen großen Einfluss
und der größte Antagonist zum dopamin
ist das Serotonin also während Dopamin
die ständig einpeitscht ja und Sache und
dir sagt ich will Freude rauschgl
das ist krachen ist sie rottonin in dir
dasjenige das hier sorgte zu Hause ist
auch ganz schön und
die herrlich entspannend und jetzt mal
ausstrecken und auf dem Sofa gemütlich
machen und so weiter also für das genug
in uns ne da ist ein bisschen richtig
gut das heißt wir haben also einen Stoff
für das genug reicht nicht das ist
Dopamin und wir haben einen im Kopf der
sagt schon ja also wenn du gerade
sagtest Richard freier Wille ne Essen
zum Beispiel auch da wieder diese Gier
ne es gibt
wahnsinnig interessante Experimente zum
Thema Essen wir wissen nicht wann genug
ist und auch da kommen wieder die
Evolutionsbiologen und sagen na gut wir
haben eigentlich dieses Appetit Gefühl
und signalisiert es ist zu wenig Nahrung
da und das war ja auch durch die meiste
Zeit der Menschheitsgeschichte hindurch
war das ja so wenn du jetzt in so einem
Wellnessbereich am Wochenende mal
irgendwo unterwegs bist da siehst du
also so richtig wenig Nahrung scheint
jetzt nicht mehr das Thema zu sein nee
es ist es ist Wahnsinn was du da siehst
und das hat natürlich damit zu tun dass
offensichtlich unser Gehirn nicht in der
Lage ist in Zeiten des Überflusses wo es
glücklicherweise kein Mangel mehr
Nahrungsmittel gibt uns rechtzeitig zu
signalisieren jetzt ist genug also auch
da immer diese Gier ich habe von einem
Experiment in Vorbereitung auf unser
Gespräch gelesen das fand ich
sensationell Suppenschüssel und es gibt
ja eine Gruppe von Probanden die ist
einfach ganz normal diese Suppe leer
und irgendwann ist das Ding leer und die
haben das Gefühl sie sind satt und alles
in bester Ordnung die andere Gruppe ist
das an der Schüssel die präpariert
worden ist das heißt durch einen
unsichtbaren Schlauch wird immer weiter
Suppe nachgefüllt mit dem Ergebnis dass
die am Ende das doppelt oder dreifache
dessen essen was die anderen essen weil
ihnen ihr Hungergefühl offensichtlich
nicht sagt ihr regier sozusagen
verbietet einfach aufzuhören das ist
doch fasziniert richtig ich war wenn man
sich mit dem mit dem mit dem Thema Masse
auseinandersetzt dann merkt man
plötzlich dass es vielleicht sogar so
sein könnte dass Gier und haben wollen
und das Anhäufen von Besitztümern und
Lagerflächen mieten weil man irgendwie
seinen ganzen krempeln irgendwo mal
unterbringt
dass das auch durchaus etwas ist worüber
wir uns wahnsinnig definieren
das heißt man kann so furchtbar
moralisch tun und sagen naja wir wir
sind alle so maßlos wir kriegen nie
genug und das Auto kann nicht groß genug
sein und der Kleiderschrank und das
Essen all die Themen die wir jetzt
gerade angesprochen haben aber die
Wahrheit ist doch Richard frage ich mich
und Frage jetzt auch an Dich willst mal
überlegst du nimmst mir jetzt zum
Beispiel all die Dinge weg die mir
persönlich wichtig sind ja zum Beispiel
Klavier Bücher auch Autos auch ich liebe
Fahrräder zum Beispiel ja du nimmst mir
all das Weg ja dann wird es mir nicht
gut gehen das zeigt mir umgekehrt wie
sehr ich mich darüber definiere das
heißt etwas zu haben etwas zu besitzen
das ist auch etwas worüber wir uns
definieren im Sinne von das gibt uns
auch halt das weiß richtig aber jetzt
auch mal wieder der die These ein
bisschen auseinander gepflückt Besitz
und Status sind zwei verschiedene Dinge
und Besitz und Lieblingsdinge auch also
man könnte natürlich auch die zehn Dinge
aufzählen die mir von meinen materiellen
Gütern die ich besitze am wichtigsten
sind aber wenn man jetzt hier in der
Kemenate die Hälfte der Bücher wegnehmen
würde was ja auch Teil meines Besitzes
ist und man würde die richtigen
wegnehmen nicht die falschen würde mir
das nichts ausmachen das heißt wir haben
ja ganz ganz viel besitzt der jetzt
nicht ja so eine richtig große Bedeutung
für uns hat und gehen wir aber trotzdem
haben einfach wenn wir ihn nicht
wegschmeißen und sagen kann ich ja nicht
einfach wegschmeißen oder wegtun oder wo
sich eine riechen das alles hin tun oder
ach ja wenn ich mal Zeit habe da müsste
ich das alles aus also du kannst
sicherlich die Hälfte der Dinge in
meinem Kleiderschrank wegnehmen du
kannst die Hälfte der Bücher wegnehmen
ja nur würde ich sagen da hätte ich
übrigens auch gar nichts gegen würde ich
mich wahrscheinlich sogar freuen wenn
ich wüsste dass es die richtigen Dinge
sind
also es wird definieren uns ja nicht
über alles was wir besitzen sondern es
gibt einige Dinge von denen die wir
besitzen die für uns gerade besonders
wichtig sind und übrigens auch Status
hängt nicht davon ab wie viel
Gegenstände jemand hat sondern ob er die
richtigen gegensteckt sagt ist genau der
Punkt also wenn jemand 200 schrottreife
Autos besitzt ja ist das nicht Status
fördert ja wenn er aber ein AMG fährt in
der richtigen Szene schon
ne die Frage ist ja ob sozusagen Konsum
das was wir immer so Geiseln wo wir
jetzt auch schon die ganze Zeit darüber
reden und sagen dass das muss aufhören
wir brauchen eine Kultur des genug aber
die Wahrheit ist ist vielleicht Konsum
etwas mehr als einfach nur die Gier nach
ständig neuem ist das vielleicht etwas
was uns ja wirklich Halt gibt John Nash
schreibt dazu total interessant
vielleicht ist dieses ziellose kaufen
einfach nur der Versuch in einer Achtung
Gottlosen Welt einen Sinn zu finden
ja sagt dann wie im Westen sind der
Meinung dass der alte übermächtige Gott
tot ist da ist niemand mehr der unsere
täglichen Dramen sieht der unsere
innersten Gedanken liest und unsere
einzige Möglichkeit
irgendeine Form von Unsterblichkeit zu
gewinnen besteht also darin in der
materiellen Welt Anerkennung zu kriegen
und zwar mittels der Dinge die wir
besitzen oder am Leib tragen oder nimmt
es eine Art
existenzielles Daumen lutschen okay ich
klug ich finde das klug und jetzt mache
ich noch eine Zwischenstufe ich glaube
an die Stelle von Gott ist in unserer
Kultur nicht der Konsum gekommen sondern
die Liebe
die romantische Liebe die paar liebe die
hat heute all die Qualitäten die früher
die das Verhältnis zu Gott ausgemacht
hat jemand der mich bedingungslos liebt
das ist der christliche christliche Gott
liebt bedingungslos anders als der des
Alten Testaments dann diese diese
Vorstellung für den anderen ein und
alles zu sein ja du bist die Welt für
mich ja ohne dich geht meine Welt unter
das ist ja alles Religiöse Metaphorik
das ja alles das ursprünglich Verhältnis
der Menschen zu Gott und an die Stelle
Gottes ist bei uns diese Liebe an das
das absolute der Liebe das unbedingt der
Liebe das ist alles an die Stelle
getreten so nun ist es ja so dass die
aller aller wenigsten Menschen eine
solche Liebe haben oder finden
und ich würde sagen der Konsum ist die
Ersatzbefriedigung dafür das also quasi
über Bande über Bande das
Gottesverhältnis aber eigentlich ist es
müsste doch eigentlich sein jemand der
sehr viel Erfüllung in der Liebe findet
was also für die Dauer eines Lebens ja
auch einmal mein Meisterwerk ist das
irgendwo hinzubekommen und zu gestalten
der müsste eigentlich keine
Sinnstiftung oder sowas primär über
Konsum haben
sollte man jedenfalls denken vielleicht
ist auch so je weniger man liebesfähig
ist umso wichtiger ist es viele Dinge zu
besitzen ja weil es uns Halt gibt da
bist du immer wieder bei diesem Thema
gibt eine amerikanischen Psychologen
Thomas schinski der der offensichtlich
polnische Wurzeln hat der sagt was auf
total irre geht genau in die Richtung
Einkaufen
einkaufen ist ein Schild der dazu dient
den potenziellen Schrecken fernzuhalten
der aus der furchtbaren Erkenntnis
resultiert pass auf dass wir Menschen
nichts sind als kurzlebige Tiere die in
einem sinnlosen Universum um ihr Leben
kämpfen und letztlich zu Tod und
Verwesung verdammt sind
gegen diesen Albtraum tragen wir Kleider
die uns zum modegöttern machen oder
benutzen Küchengeräte die uns dann zu
Haus Gott halten machen persönlich
interessant aber aber selbst
Selbstüberhöhung
ist sich ist sicherlich ein wichtiger
Konsum und der versucht dem Ganzen einen
Sinn zu geben und in dem Moment wo du
sozusagen diesen Sinn nicht mehr kriegst
über Religion oder an ein Gott den du
glaubst machst du es eben genauso ich
finde das schon was dran also das wäre
so paralleligiöses Verhältnis von Konsum
haben glaube ich auch weil wir in der
Geschichte keine andere Kultur finden
werden bei der das so ausgeprägt ist wie
bei uns heute aber ich glaube nicht dass
es an unserem Wirbeltier Gehirn liegt
das kann man mit unserem Gehirn machen
muss man aber nicht sondern das ist
tatsächlich an der Kultur liegt in der
wir leben und das ist ja auch allgemein
so akzeptiert ich meine überleg mal
Prasserei Völlerei Gier und so das waren
ja alles im Mittelalter Todsünden ja
also das was was wenn man heute sagt
genug ist nicht genug ja ist das exakt
das Gegenteil der Lebenseinstellung die
das christliche Mittelalter vertreten
ist richtig oder die der Buddhismus
vertritt ja also die die ganzen
fernöstlichen Religionen mit ihrem Ziel
der Bedürfnislosigkeit das krasseste
Gegenteil und wir haben ja auch
Milliarden Anhänger ja das wie sehr das
denn heute so ist und ob diese
Gesellschaft nicht längst überformt sind
ist eine andere Frage aber über lange
Jahrhunderte hinweg war das so das heißt
Menschen sind zu A B C oder D F ja das
ist wahr ich habe ich habe von
Experimenten mit Kindern gelesen oder
Untersuchungen
Kinderpsychologen und Psychiater die
sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben
unter anderem den kybootsemin in Israel
und anderen Orten die sagen nee es ist
nicht so dass das angezogen ist Dinge
haben zu wollen sondern Kinder sind von
Anfang an sehr auch auf materielle Dinge
aus und das beobachtet man ja auch es
ist für Kinder wichtig ganz bestimmte
Dinge ihr Eigentum nennen das das erlebe
ich selber so im Alltag auch und
definieren
das ist nicht nur angezogen das habe ich
von Anfang an gesagt ich habe gesagt wir
könnten als gar nicht Menschen
anerziehen wenn sie nicht eine
Disposition dafür hätten nur Menschen
und das habe ich auch gesagt haben viele
Dispositionen und die Frage ist welche
Disposition wird besonders gefördert und
welche wird weniger gefördert
das Eigentum für Kinder wichtig ist das
weiß ich noch von mir selber also ich
besitze heute noch das Spielzeug aus
meiner Kindheit was wir am wichtigsten
war nämlich
ich habe eigentlich meine ganze Kindheit
über mit dem gleichen gespielt mein
Vater hat mir von Krups der Firma wohl
gearbeitet hat als Industriedesigner
Holz mitgebracht und zwar wurden die
Modelle für die Küchengeräte früher in
Holzformen gemacht aus hochwertigem Holz
und die hat er geschliffen und die bekam
ich als Bauklötze davon hatte ich sehr
sehr viele und ich hatte das was man
heute Schleich Tiere nennt die hießen
die hießen früher waren gab es eine
englische Firma Britains limited die die
herstellten und elastholin zu hießen
hier gibt es heute nicht mehr und mit
diesen Tieren von denen ich eine
unendliche Sammlung habe dafür dass ich
insgesamt wenig Spielzeuge hatte hatte
ich davon ganz ganz viel und auch in
diese Bauklötze und da konnte man alles
mitmachen also nicht nur Zoos bauen man
konnte die ja auch mit menschlichen
Charakteren ausstatten und Städte damit
bauen und Bogen und so weiter und dieser
Besitz war mir ich hatte ja vier
Geschwister
wo ständig irgendwas geklaut wird ja
also
dieser Holzklasse ist dann später im
Hobbykeller vernagelt worden ja und
furchtbar aus ja und da hat mir das Herz
geblutet mit jedem Nagel den ich da
rausgezogen habe und den Löchern die ich
darin gesehen habe also das Kinder sowas
haben und ich bin ja nun nicht so super
materialistisch erzogen das glaube ich
sofort aber dass sie ein eingeborenes
gehen dafür haben nie genug zu kriegen
das werden andere These möglicherweise
zum Schluss gesprochen Richard es gibt
wenn man sich mal einliest in diese
Materie gibt es jemanden auf dem man
stößt mit dem ich nie gerechnet hätte
einer meiner lieblings Schriftsteller
ist Alexander solche initien
den ich Ihnen sehr jungen Jahren schon
kennengelernt habe haben wir glaube ich
mal drüber gesprochen ein Tag im Leben
des Ivan der nicht so witzig er ist ein
kleines dünnes Büchlein das den schoola
vorgelesen Wahnsinn genau über dieses
wecken morgens um fünf irgendwo in
Sibirien was ich nicht wusste ist
in der ja später den Nobelpreis bekommen
hat der hat nicht nur das sowjetische
abgelehnt sondern der hat auch unsere
westliche Lebensweise abgelehnt und als
sehr unheilvoll beschrieben und seiner
Meinung nach haben wir nachdem wir
unsere religiösen und moralischen
Grundsätze über Bord geworfen haben das
Verständnis für gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt und den Sinn des Lebens
verloren und er sagt unser Streben nach
persönlichem Besitz ist alles was uns
geblieben ist und bald werden wir nur
noch eine Horde zerstreuter Konsumenten
sein und er stellt dem dagegen an den
Begriff weil ich überdenke den müsste
man mal laut in so einer Shopping Mall
aussprechen Selbstbeherrschung wenn du
wenn du mit dem Begriff kommst dann
zerstörst du im Grunde genau dieses
System Selbstbeherrschung ist ja das was
systemisch absolut nicht gewollt ist
richtig und Selbstbeherrschung ist eine
wichtige Tugend des Mittelalters selbst
Forschungsnetz zentrale Tugend der alten
also zum klassischen Werte Kanon des
Abendlandes gehört Selbstbeherrschung
absolut dazu allerdings muss man sagen
ist ja Selbstbeherrschung hat ja auch
eine Schattenseite das ging hieß ja auch
immer keine Emotionen zeigen gehört auch
zur selbstbehör also dass der Mensch
sich selbst kontrollieren soll und nicht
so sein wonach ihm gerade ist ist das
krasseste Gegenteil unserer Kultur
Matrix heute das war in der es nur um in
erster Linierung Emotionen geht und so
weiter und natürlich klar die Fähigkeit
zur Selbstbeherrschung ist eine ganz
ganz wichtige Fähigkeit als Umgang mit
sich selbst und im materiellen wie im
emotionalen und genau wenn du mal
abschließend sozusagen den Gedanken
weiterspinnst nur mal auf das Materielle
bezogen ja
wir würden immer sagen ja
Selbstbeherrschung klar das ist Teil
unserer Kulturgeschichte und so weiter
aber die Wahrheit ist unsere Vorfahren
auch unsere Eltern meine Mutter zum
Beispiel Selbstbeherrschung dass das
kann die das muss ich Dir nicht erklären
es versteht die ganz genau
und das fällt ja auch überhaupt nicht
schwer aber unsere Generation und dann
auch noch mal unsere Kinder die müssen
das doch in Wahrheit alles erst wieder
lernen diese Fähigkeit ist unser Banken
gekommen
ja ja also die ist uns abhanden gekommen
ob eine eigentlich positiven Entwicklung
nämlich der Entwicklung dass man heute
Gefühle zeigen darf auch nicht
uneingeschränkt und nicht überall und so
weiter aber Emotionalität und
Befindlichkeit spielen heute eine
größere Rolle als in jeder anderen
menschlichen Kultur die wir kennen genau
und die andere Seite ist wenn wir
darüber aber die Fähigkeit zur
Selbstbeherrschung zu verlieren ja dann
ist das natürlich völlig richtig eine
Gesellschaft die zu Selbstbeherrschung
nicht fähig ist oder deren Bürger zur
Selbstbeherrschung nicht fähig ist die
treibt in den Untergang
das ist tatsächlich so man muss das
nicht unbedingt mit den düsteren Farben
von solchen Medizinen machen der ja auch
quasi ein sehr sehr konservativer Mensch
der wollte ja eigentlich sozusagen also
der hatte seine emotionalen Wurzeln im
Zarenreich so richtig ja und auch in
einer Welt in der die Kirche noch eine
andere Rolle spielt in der es sozusagen
die Geborgenheit der Tradition gab und
wir leben ja heute auch in einer
Gesellschaft in der Traditionen verloren
gehen ja also wir leben in einer
Diktatur der Gegenwärtigkeit alles
sofort und hier und jetzt auch im
Konsumverhalten eine Kultur der sofort
nützlich warten können aber dieses so
sagen ja jeder ist heben wir uns auf und
das machen wir nicht und deine Eltern
deine Großeltern haben übrigens auch
schon immer und so weiter dass man so
eingebunden ist ja das in so
Verhaltensweisen die man so macht und
die so eine mythische Tiefe haben
Traditionen eben wir leben ja in einer
Gesellschaft des totalen
Traditionsverlust ist und wahrscheinlich
das was soll chinesien unter anderem ja
an an der wohlschevistischen Revolution
verurteilt hat ja da kommen die
Bolschewiki ja Lenin und Konsorten und
sagen wir erfinden jetzt einen neuen
Menschen und machen alles neu und im
Kapitalismus hat er das auf eine andere
Art und Weise eben auch wieder gefunden
Leute die alles neu machen wollen und
immer neue Anreize und wo das
traditionelle kein Wert hat und das war
das worunter solch Medizin gelitten ja
deswegen schienen wir auch dieser
Begriff der der Selbstbeherrschung auch
gerade für das Ende unseres Gesprächs
ich finde das vom guten Begriff das
klingt so banal und das klingt so
selbstverständlich aber die Wahrheit ist
wir haben
verlernt was das eigentlich wirklich
heißt Selbstbeherrschung ich meine wir
reden jetzt wieder über Dinge die wir
uns lange nicht mehr vorstellen konnten
wir reden über Mangel nicht nur über die
gasmangellage wir reden über Mangel auf
ganz vielen Ebenen wir reden plötzlich
wieder über Verzicht und du merkst wie
wir uns damit quälen wie wir uns
Schulen und sofort mit dem
fingerspolitiker hat das genau ja
genau du musst verzichten aber ich bitte
bitte nicht bei mir und das ist
sozusagen das ist der krasse
Gegenentwurf zu Amazon Prime ja das
stimmt und kein Politiker hat es bei uns
geschafft Verzicht als Chance zu sehen
und dazu stellen ja richtig wobei das
zum Teil eben so ist und ich komme ja
damit noch mal zu zu meiner Aussage die
ich schon mal gemacht habe und die mir
im Augenblick gerade im Blick auf Herbst
und Winter so wichtig ist
dass die Tatsache dass wir in diesem
Winter vor dem Problem stehen dass wir
nicht genug Energie haben wahrscheinlich
genug Gas haben dass wir da auf etwas
verzichten müssen verzichten müssen die
Heizung so weit hoch zu drehen ist so
das klassische Beispiel aber auch vieles
andere verzichten zu müssen ist ja eine
Vorübung für das was wir aus
ökologischen Gründen ohnehin machen das
ist wir lernen müssen ja das heißt nicht
das heißt nicht dass wir uns nicht alle
Mühe geben müssen bessere
sozialverträglich für möglich zu machen
und das gerecht auf die Schultern zu
verteilen das ist eine ganz wichtige
Aufgabe aber die allgemeine Stoßrichtung
das hier plötzlich etwas weniger wird
wir haben weniger Gas zur Verfügung wir
müssen mit weniger umgehen
das ist ein eine Sache die ich
gleichzeitig auch als Chance sehe denn
eine Kultur eine Gesellschaft die
verlernt hat mit einem weniger umzugehen
in einer Zeit wo sie sich ihren
Lebensstil so nicht mehr leisten kann
ist ja eigentlich notwendig und ich
würde mir wünschen dass unsere Politiker
die positive Seite dessen viel mehr
hervorkehren würden und eben auch sagen
dass das hier eine um eine Verhaltens
Angleichung geht und Verhaltensänderung
geht und ein eine neue Justierung geht
die wir ja eben auch aus ökologischen
Gründen brauchen und eben nicht nur
wegen des Krieges das fände ich sehr
sehr wichtig und damit ich nicht falsch
verstanden werde natürlich ist ein
riesiges Problem wenn Leute die sehr
wenig Geld haben auf einmal eine riesige
Gasrechnung kriegen und völlig klar ist
dass der Staat der Pflicht ist ja die
Verteilung auf die Schultern gerechter
zu machen aber dass wir mit weniger
umgehen müssen ja und die haben gar kein
anderer Chance als mit weniger umzugehen
wir werden es vermutlich ja 100%
kompensiert kriegen das ist doch eine
gute und wichtige Übung
ja zumindest etwas das irgendwann mal
eine aussprechen muss du hast das gerade
getan ich warte auf den Moment bis dass
das erste Mal bei uns in der Sendung
wirklich passiert ist noch nicht ist
noch nicht da gewesen das wird aber so
schnell nicht kommen genau keiner will
der erste sein Richard ich danke Dir
sehr hat Spaß gemacht mit dir über eine
Kultur des genug zu sprechen und die
eine gute Woche bis nächste Woche ja
wünsche ich dir tschüss Markus ciao ciao
ciao
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]